avec moundir face à gilbert notamment
[Rires]
deux trois tops pas possible alors il
est pas mauvais
on dira ne lâche pas frérot tout est
dans la tête j'ai beau me dire s'il te
plaît ne lâche pas aller tout est dans
l'avenir
[Musique]
moundir j'avais battu gilles verdez mais
j'ai fait exprès tout ça tout ça c'était
voilà un petit peu car j'ai amené web
champions ça va il va défier art c'est
un immense champion
c'est un garçon que j'adore c'est
vraiment un de mes amis il est avec nous
ce soir
il est champion olympique et lui il veut
défier moumni retour au poids
tonino 4
[Applaudissements]
le soin qu'on peut rester jusqu'à 21h30
comme ça
[Musique]
moundir pense à denis brogniart
c'est dans la tête vous nuire
moi j'ai mon pote l'aï je peux venir
c'est que celui-là je te lâcherai jamais
eu lieu on va vous dire je rappelle que
vous dire hé ben a gagné contre la
terreur gilles verdez pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent
vous dire attention
ma fille minutes les gars une fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sony veut pas lâcher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remarquez quand même que tu fais jamais
les épreuves subies mais quelqu'un fort
et début je n'ai pas pensé
[Applaudissements]
mais je fasse le poids contre camille
combal faire fort bon là ça va durer
beaucoup moins lourd attention c'est
parti
trois deux un tintin tintin cette façon
comment ils sont très longtemps
vraiment
le jour
assez pour tony yoka
marché couvert
les amis qu'on abat la deuxième elle
faisait la manche au large
là c'est bon tu auras ton portable lâche
ma famille avec amis l'avantagé par ap
[Applaudissements]